大家分享一个特别简单,特别铺实的,让你变得越来越好的方法
到底很简单
但是
你真的要好好地理解他
然后把他试试,真正的东西都是非常简写的
首先给你一会儿做我们
不是知道对立啊,只是只让大家说你们没这个我计
普通人做情工人被什么会几种,因为很多时候他该卖钱都有的
从这个做事
尤其是靠写电车轻转钱
做人靠着系统
我拿我自己来说,其实我每天
的工作时间做两个小事
而且这个还是因为我想工作不愿意工作
如果只是被的生存的话其实我每天只需要工作二十分多就好了
为什么
比如说我去拍照短片,我分钟
就是拿过来就可以拍了
为什么我是有系统,比如说我口资
跑资的话其实大概早一点我就会去做了
因为很多事情都是有系统的
包括做事也是一样的
那么很多人就会问这个系统怎么来
系统的话我可以给大家讲两个事,因为我给大家一个正式的案例
就经过这个案例就没到得该怎么做了
另外以后给大家一个具体的方法
首先这个案例呢
不见拿你的案例好吗
你做游戏的案例可以吗
可以吗
会说呀
就是我姑娘
就是他们放春价,放春价有两天
两天他就想做
想玩游戏,我说你玩游戏
你不如自己做个游戏吧
然后我就做个游戏,其实我们做的来游戏对吗
三个吧,今天还做个才知道
对,我们做三游戏
咱们拿你那个小短特的游戏
没利子可以吗
我们拿那个小短短特的利子一开始是不是知误
我们最开始做的时候,只有一个小小uger是吧
你就是个小小tober
那小球给我
小男球
小男球 好了这小男球
小男球最开始只能干吗
只能
大枪
真 那枪,一开始就是枪啊
一开始就只有枪
后来你加了什么
还有
还有脘身既还有
那个气抠
是下 kell的下مر家的直升面机和气忽
嗚染 汉
然后不是是下午
下午反那个
还是下午反那个
直升机换成飞机
换成飞机了
把直升机换成飞机了
然后加了点
然后今天
你昨天加了房子
该了房子
然后今天加了那个羽毛
今天都对吧
今天都觉得要加羽毛
那个羽毛
你当时是游戏怎么设计的
你跟他说
打一个坏人
掉一个
不是你说的吗
我说的是羽毛
是你掉的是你说的
不是我说的是那个彩底羽毛
彩底羽毛
对你彩底羽毛
你彩底羽毛彩底
几个
然后变成彩底
变成羽毛变成
吃吧
主要是那个
汽车菜是无敌的
而且我们这开始是
是平面的
后浪版的变成
2D的
就是变成了那种
立体的半立体的
假假立体的对不对
对 是吧
很让人有个硬子
对 还有仰子
所以我跟大家讲
我们在玩的游戏
作为游戏的时候
刚才是特别特别简单
就是个就是个小球
后来的话
觉得玩了玩了没意思
然后我们就开始
出了个小短图
就出了个小姑娘
可以导致
后来有加各种道具
跟加各种游戏规则
这个游戏规则
还有改的吗
不改的
这么玩的是
明天咱们是是吧
看看在个的
加点心中心
其实我要买了
它很正单的
对呀
咱们现在的加一点点好不好
你加点游戏规则
咱们的加一点好不好
对
我给大家讲那个例子
什么例子
就是
其实你会发现
刚开始的那个系统
就是一点点
然后你觉得做的
你觉得
就是我可以做的更好的一点
然后你有加个游戏规则
然后你做的做
就可以加一个游戏规则
我讲什么
就是系统本之上
不是一开始就了系统
是你先有一个很小的东西
然后你发现
你可以在他们增加一点东西
然后再增加一点
然后再增加一点系统
我都得去游户
那么我们这个系统该怎么够见呢
其实方法很简单
就是当你做成了一件事
时候
你把他记住下来
你要做什么事
然后你不一步一步
一步是怎么把它做成的
然后你后面再去
再去遇到这个事情的时候
你发现
这里边有一个
有一个大格
有一个问题
有一个缺险
然后你把它改过来
一定要避开这个缺险
然后你做的东西
还有更好的方法
然后你把这个方
更好的方法再加在
过画的这个系统里面
然后可能突然有一天
你突然有什么来这里
哇
原来还可以这么做
你又把这个
秒招
就把这个巧招
用方的这个系统里面
后来你这个系统
变得越来越强大
然后他就可以
用软软软软的
然后那个
后来
然后你可能就会玩的
特别爽
对吧
所以你的系统
一旦运动起来
就越来越来爽
对不对
所以各位看
天天办了
就是系统的这么高点
一康是适合一点点
把你做事的方法
把它固化成的
然后你后来发现
八个改一下
然后你发现更好的方法
再把它固化成
然后这个系统会变得越来越好
越来越生成
最后用
忙着的一句话
给大家去总结一下
你好好思考一下
就是
人是怎么变数的呢
其实就是
你发现什么东西是有用的
然后不断的用的
然后想办法
怎么让他变得越来越好用
发现什么东西是没有的
然后
不再用的